is a creator economy recession
improbable or inevitable in this video
we're going to be looking at a new
article from business insider that
reveals 40 influencer marketing insiders
describing how the economic downturn has
already hit
their industry we're also going to be
looking at a survey from the think media
community
about is your cpm or your rpm going up
or down in fact let me know in the
comments have you noticed any increases
or decreases in your ad revenue
and then we're also going to be talking
about four practical actions you can
take right now to recession proof your
income and thrive over the coming months
all of that and more is coming up today
on the coffee with kennel show
[Music]
welcome back to coffee with kennel my
name is sean cannell and i'm super fired
up to dive into this content today um
there's a lot of of course drama kind of
happening in the news cycle and there's
a lot of talk of recession so we're
going to look at real data and you can
make your own decisions remember here at
think media and the think media podcast
we're on a mission to help you win so we
just want to give you the data but we're
coming from an optimistic perspective
you know i don't believe that god has
given us a spirit of fear but a spirit
of power and of love and of a sound mind
to make wise and strategic decisions
over the coming months and
the fact is recession is not inevitable
and we're actually going to be looking
at people a lot smarter than me however
there is a lot of drama out there and
here's one of the articles that's super
interesting so business insider uh
talked to 40 influencer marketing
insiders to see how
this was uh everything that's going on
is affecting their industries and here's
come kind of the headlines brands are
canceling campaigns and delaying
payments to creators as they brace for
downturns you know google just announced
that they are slowing hiring so a lot of
tech companies a lot of brands that
sponsor creators are either canceling
campaigns or they're delaying payments
to creators
and some creators were saying they have
struggled to land new deals and that
affiliate commissions are down and then
business insider spoke to dozens and
creators about how they're adjusting to
the economy and the big idea here and
we're going to be talking about this
towards the end of this video so
definitely stick around
is you got to prepare and
position yourself now right it's just
wise to be wise isn't it it's smart to
be smart um we don't want to stick our
head in the sand we don't want to be
overly paranoid or worried we just want
to be
action takers that prepare
for the potentially shaking a calm
economy but here's the article i really
want to talk about and business insider
uh was talking about is a recession
improbable or inevitable jp morgan
goldman sachs and 10 other top investing
firms revealed their predictions for the
economy for the rest of 2022 and what's
shocking here
is that there is dramatically different
opinions so you've got experts saying
things like a recession is highly
unlikely unemployment is historically
low consumers are continuing to spend
and go on vacations
and inflation isn't actually going to be
as sticky as many people think it's
going to believe so some of the top
experts are like it's actually pretty
unlikely
the flip side jp morgan chase ceo jamie
dimon says it's possible but it's
doubtful
and so again
i'm not a financial advisor i'm not
deeply intertwined into the markets
these are people that are a lot smarter
than me
and jpmorgan chase is saying yeah maybe
but maybe not
and i think that's good news because you
might ask sean well how should that
affect my behavior is there is it going
to happen is it not going to happen i
feel like you're not giving me a solid
answer here's what we can do we're going
to be talking about four things
you can do
regardless of circumstances around you
because
you can't control circumstances around
you but you can control your own
thoughts your own actions your own
attitude and as i go on in this article
another expert said it's about a coin
flip given the economic environment is
highly uncertain several firms are
saying it's about 50 percent chance
oh it's 50 i don't know well i need
solid information look one thing i've
learned in today's 2022 world that
certainty
is something that is not available to
anybody like certainty is not something
that any of us ultimately have but what
we can be certain right is about our own
emotional health mental toughness and
there are some actions that we can take
because other experts barclays private
bank is saying a recession is more
likely
than not we recently had patrick bett
david speak at our conference grow with
video live and he's looking at all the
numbers and he thinks it's highly likely
bank of america says count on it you
know and you look at different numbers
how much money has been printed so
what does that mean for us well in just
a second i want to talk about the action
items uh we can get into but i also did
a survey and then this isn't like an
official survey but i went on twitter
and i asked is your cpm up or down right
now compared to last year for those
following me on twitter and if you ever
want to connect on social media in the
corner of this video at sean cannell
rhymes with youtube channel
is where i'm at on instagram and twitter
but i threw out this question and i was
curious you know compared to this time
last year because
the way you earn money specifically
through
youtube and getting views on your videos
is through ad revenue and the way
youtube pays you is that brands are
willing to pay them
money that youtube splits and it's
roughly a 55 45 split it seems to vary
depending on the creator but let's just
pretend it's 50 50. that means that an
advertiser let's say it's purple
mattresses you know it's like i want to
start running ads on creators videos
great so they pay youtube and then
youtube starts to place the ads they
keep some of the money and they give you
some of the money then the question is
if less advertisers are buying ad
revenue if they're not willing to pay as
much
if they're not bidding up how much they
pay to run those ad spots
then you could see a decline potentially
in your rpm or your cpm i think the
other thing to consider here is this is
not very scientific data because your ad
revenue might be down because you stop
posting videos your ad revenue might be
down because the quality of your videos
is down you might need a fresh wind of
creativity or a fresh wind of just
uploading and hustle so there's a lot of
variables but i think that this is
interesting in and of itself is uh rebel
don said it's up devon said it's a big
up like
uh these are two that are saying since
last year
our revenue
is up at think media we are up if only
slightly since last year we have not
seen
a downturn in our cpm or rpm
yet
however it depends i think on your niche
and i'd love to hear from you in the
comments have you experienced it going
down havoc says down sadly
um you know some just got partnered so
they have nothing to measure it against
martin's saying it's down jen's saying
it's up way up some are saying um it has
improved to a night and day difference
anthony is saying and i think
roberto blake our friend roberto right
who's uh helping creators create awesome
it's about the same at 32
so so we're seeing
that fluctuating and i think a lot of
people in our community too if they
compare to last year all i'm actually
asking you to do and here's how you do
it you actually go into your youtube
studio because sure there's the views
side of things but what you actually
want to be checking is you go to your
analytics you go to your
revenue and you're going to see two
numbers you're going to see your cpm and
your rpm now here on our think media
podcast channel these are pretty high
numbers our cpm is 40 and 24 cents uh
our rpm 1728 and it's always fluctuating
right and so then you could look at
different date ranges and so uh let's
see in the last 365
it's kind of stayed pretty steady right
around 40. but again it's gonna depend
and and here on think media podcast it's
a very much crater minded business
minded entrepreneur minded build your
creator business you know learn how to
use youtube to grow your revenue uh to
generate more leads and sales or to
build a creator business you know all
that kind of thing so
we've seen that our rpm on this channel
is even higher than our other channel
fake media but let me know if you feel
like your income has gone up or down so
what's the point here i think the point
is to say that i would really agree with
this business insider article
that
it's kind of 50 50. experts are saying
it's kind of a coin toss of whether or
not we are absolutely going into an
economic downturn or recession the other
thing is that sometimes
people have like you know it's kind of
scary it's kind of a click bait thing
but it also a recession might be mild it
just might mean that the gdp that's how
we measure it here in the u.s
just did not go up for two consecutive
quarters that doesn't necessarily mean
it's going to affect your pocketbook
your personal life your personal creator
business your personal niche on the flip
side
it will affect certain industries
certain crater economy businesses are
laying people off jelly smack downsized
their staff by eight percent that's a
crater academy economy business so it's
gonna depend so so what do we do about
it like what is our actions that we need
to take well i wanna always uh keep this
practical and not
give false hope and not just give out
platitudes of positivity but i think
there's something really powerful about
having an optimistic outlook
and having real strategies and i want to
give you four of them but i have a
couple
uh quotes that i think frame what we're
doing here at think media one is from
proverbs 22 3 it says a prudent person
with insight foresees danger coming and
prepares himself for uh for it
so a prudent person that has insight and
that's what we're after here in fact if
you're not subscribed i encourage you to
subscribe we want to give you insights
data strategy why because you could see
danger coming what if danger doesn't
come well thank god we're prepared
but if danger does come we're preparing
ourselves now pablo picasso said it like
this action is the foundational key for
all success
what does that mean it means that right
now is not a time to freeze
this is not a time to only focus on
defense this actually is a time to take
action
because the best way to respond is to
take action i actually love this quote
from barack obama that says the best way
to not feel hopeless
is to get up and do something
what do i do in response to this
information get up and do something
he says this don't wait for good things
to happen to you if you go out and make
some good things happen
you will fill the world with hope and
you will fill yourself with hope man i
love that because there's something
about right now as there are uncertain
times and even fearful times man it's
time to get up and do something and fill
yourself with hope and fill the world
with hope that's why i love youtube we
have a chance to create content make
videos
share goodness in the world answer
questions entertain people and create
meaningful content that can fill the
world with hope what also happens you
punch despair and depression in the face
when you're productive when you actually
punch fear in the face and press record
and make something you build up your own
confidence and you actually are
injecting confidence and hope into
others bringing solutions not just
fixating on problems but looking at the
possibilities
so that's kind of our
stance that's our lean at think media
right now we're leaning into hope we're
leaning into optimism and we're leaning
in to
faith for this coming season but here
are four things that uh i would say
we're doing and if you're getting value
hit the like button um on this video on
the coffee with kennel show today
and i have four things that we should
all do like this is the thing to do now
and this is super important because
again i want you to win
i want you to be smart so here's number
one cut unnecessary spending cut
unnecessary spending i really think that
especially if it's a coin toss right now
that we're going into recession and that
it could really affect your pocketbook
it would not be the time
to just again assume that it's just
going to be up and up and up and up as
it's been in the past
cut unnecessary spending it's a good
time to be a little bit more
conservative in stat cash and i'm just
sharing what we're doing so we're
looking over our credit card statements
sonya my wife uh runs our books
personally and she's our cfo for our
company think media so i'm like looking
what is unnecessary that is on our
credit card every month what can we cut
i'm asking do we really need that right
now i'm asking is that really an asset
or a liability right now and i'm also
asking because one of the things we need
to realize is that actually hidden in
every obstacle and challenge is a seed
of equal or greater opportunity
so one of the
powerful reasons to cut spending is to
have cash not just to write out the
storm but to actually take action on
potentially distressed assets or to
actually lean in to growth but it's hard
to grow or it's hard to focus on
building your side hustle or a crater
economy business
if you don't have any cash so number one
you know cut unnecessary spending
number two is learn valuable
skills
i think the greatest response in times
of uncertainty is kind of like barack
obama said um the best way to not feel
hopeless is to get up and do something
and i would say one of the best ways to
start building your hope is to get up
and learn something
what new skills are you working on right
now
what are you learning right now what's
in your pdp
sean what's a pdp well i'm glad you
asked you don't have a pdp that's your
personal development plan
how could you
intentionally be at a further place than
you are today if you don't have an
intentional plan to get there that's why
you have a pdp it's a personal
development plan
if you failed a plan you plan to fail
well sean i feel like i haven't grown in
the last couple years well you probably
didn't plan your growth
what is your pdp what is your personal
development
plan you want to learn valuable skills
why because if there's an economic
downturn listen when companies do
layoffs they never lay everybody off
unless they go bankrupt
who are they going to lay off
the least valuable team members
it's just true
who are they going to keep those that
are continuing to grow and add to their
skills
or those who stopped growing and are
this in the same place that they were
three four five years ago
invest in valuable skills
so one of the best ways to recession
proof your income
is to invest in valuable skills i like
to think about this also as inset
assets versus liabilities i read a book
in 28 2008 or 2007. it changed my life
you may have heard of the book it's
called rich dad poor dad by robert
kiyosaki have you read that
any kind of books and resources i'll
make sure to link up in the description
but one of the reasons this book changed
my life is because it talked it said
that the rich and the wealthy they
invest in
assets
and the poor invest in liabilities and
you could sound you could say oh that
sounds like judgmental and title
language no no hang on
don't cancel me
robert said it cancel robert kiyosaki
like
if you just go buy another pair of shoes
unless you're flipping shoes that's
that's a liability you lost money those
will get dirty they'll wear out they're
not gonna even be on trend in six months
to a year
whereas if you invest in skills
you're more valuable a year later so
liabilities are things that
just waste your money
you have nothing to show for it tomorrow
you just have more clutter in your
storage unit you just have a bunch of
stuff that really doesn't matter you're
just buying stuff
to impress people that you don't even
like
you know and with things you don't even
need
whereas on the flip side
if you're investing in assets what's an
asset well of course assets could be
things like businesses or real estate
but your greatest asset is you
so one of the best ways you could get
prepared to be ready
to pivot during economic downtimes to be
ready
to maximize and grow is to keep learning
keep growing so you can see what's
happening you have strategic insights is
to keep learning and keep growing new
skills
in the creator economy world you think
about all the skills you need to learn
how do i edit video that's a valuable
skill
how do i storytell valuable skill how do
i create thumbnails that's a valuable
skill how do i write powerful titles
that get people to click that's a
powerful skill how do i communicate
better and communicate persuasively
powerful skill so investing in skill
what are you doing to invest in your
skills and here's what's interesting
like this isn't just my opinion maybe
you've heard of warren buffett before
warren buffett is the founder of
berkshire hathaway hathaway one of the
most wealthy investors in the world
um and uh billionaire wright and what's
interesting is he actually shared at
their recent berkshire hathaway annual
meeting
on how
to inflation-proof your earnings
how do you inflation proof your earnings
okay so like what's he gonna say what
what does warren have to say and listen
to this according to buffett the best
thing you can do
is to be exceptionally good
at something
the best investment by far
is anything that develops yourself
wow
so
inflation's going up recession's going
crazy who knows what's gonna happen
invest in yourself
the best thing and i quote warren
buffett that you can do is to also get
exceptionally good at something
see
i live in attention especially because
you know my background i was a pastor
for years and i was a pastor in irvine
california for a while
did weddings did funerals i've been
through a lot of ups and downs with
people
and so there's part of me
that of course has empathy for everybody
that thinks about the circumstances you
go through the hardships the things
you've had to carry
and knows that you need encouragement
you need empathy like we never
know what other people have been through
we never want to be judgmental of other
people
until you've walked a mile in someone's
shoes
don't really give your opinion
so i carry that intention but here's
what i also carry that intention with
when recession starts to come
and some people get crushed
i gotta ask myself deep down i say
okay what were they doing in the good
times
were they really though
preparing for famine
or were they just blowing all their
money
were you just playing video games or
were you leveling up your skills
were you just re drinking beer
or reading books
and so
if trouble comes
and a tsunami takes you out
could there have been something you did
over the previous years when trouble
wasn't here to be preparing for the
storm
i mean that's biblical right that's
that's that's joseph having
prophetic insight to see that there's
going to be seven years of famine so
he's storing up grain what would have
happened if there wasn't famine he would
have had extra grain
and so there's just something about
if you're not taking it upon yourself to
get exceptionally good at something
people will always be employed during
down times
youtube channels will always be growing
if others are struggling my challenge to
you today
is what are you working on
becoming exceptionally good at
have you settled in your learning and
your development
or are you continuing to invest in your
skills you know abraham lincoln said
give me six hours to chop down a tree
and i'll spend the first four hours
sharpening the axe
last year our theme at think media was
sharpen the axe we gave our whole team
axes
kind of kind of weird it's kind of
sketchy
and
it's actually ecclesiastes verse that
says you know sharpen the axe using a
dull blade
will wear you out that's why you're
sharping the axe that's the value of
wisdom it helps you succeed
what does that mean it means there's
something about investing and learning
new skills if you want insurance against
inflation if you want to recession proof
your income your job sean are you saying
that you can guarantee i'm not going to
be laid off no there's no way i could
guarantee anything like that but i could
guarantee you get another job if you are
investing in new and current and
relevant skills i can guarantee that you
will always be in demand and and have
demand for your talents and your
abilities and your content
if you have relevant skills
so what is your pvp and what skills are
you working on building right now let me
know in the comments maybe one skill you
want to learn over the next few months
number three hit like if you're getting
value
start a side hustle start a side hustle
so this is interesting business insider
said when a recession hits it's more
likely you'll start your own business
even if you didn't plan to right now 17
million americans are self-employed the
highest share of the workforce since
2008 and self-employment is
counter-cyclical says uh keith meaning
that many people turn to it during
recessions if another recession's on the
horizon it could push even more
americans to self-employment and this is
kind of interesting because this has
actually been my story of
we started our business in a recession
in 2009
uber airbnb
you know these different companies
actually started which was a recession
here in america
and so did clear vision media my wife
and i started our parent company which
that sounds like real fancy yo we're
small town kids college dropouts you
know what i mean like we uh started our
company we started an llc and i started
you know making websites and doing
wedding videos and doing stuff out of my
bedroom but look at where well look what
it turned into
we uploaded our first video back in
uh
in 2010 on my personal channel and on
think media
and it's been a it's been a crazy
journey and so i want to encourage you
there's something about really getting
focused on starting a side hustle even
while you might have your main hustle so
let me know are you
in a side hustle season right now where
you have like your youtube channel but
you also got your main job are you in
like are you solopreneur maybe you're
you're all in already
as like uh
in the crater economy full time or
you're a business owner using youtube or
maybe you're in the scale season where
you're hiring a team and you're working
on you know things like that
this is a great time to start a side
hustle anytime is a great time but this
is a great time especially because you
want to start preparing now
right for what's coming and i want to
show you practically because you might
ask okay
how could i start you know a side hustle
and actually
there's a lot of things you could do
right you could start actually
freelancing on the side you could start
uber or lyft driving um you could start
something sean how do i get extra money
getting out of their job
like that's how you do it it's a lot of
people do that they they
well sean i i my money's capped i'm
working 32 hours a week and like my
money's capped
why don't you go pick up another 10 or
20 hours of work
yeah but
i'm just i don't know your circumstances
but i'm just saying like
you can start a side hustle you could
start selling stuff on etsy you could
start doing e-commerce you could do drop
shipping in my opinion
starting a youtube channel is one of the
best side hustles you could start
and
here's my story because if you look
here's a video i did 11 years ago
so i this is our house which at the time
this house
was
under short sale because the housing
bubble burst it was a 360 000 house
which is crazy because it's like double
that today had we been able to hang on
to it but we couldn't because uh it was
underwater it cut like in half it was
literally almost a 50 drop
but i'm in the bedroom before we moved
to las vegas from this situation and and
i and i started see remember i started a
business a video production i'm doing
wedding videos so i started to talk
about what i knew which for me was video
and what i did was i started to review
some of the gear that i invested in for
my business and i started to do
affiliate marketing and so this was 11
years ago right this was in
2011 now i guess is that 10 years ago or
something and and then i would talk
about like this optica x grip versus a
cam caddy scorpion or whatever i did
this one about how cause i was balling
on a budget so i i had
a canon 7d dslr but i bought used nikor
lenses
um for my dslr
so i could use these manual lenses from
ebay that were like 50
and
and adapt them onto my camera but what
the cool thing was was again so i was
solving problems and i'm helping other
people also who maybe want to save money
on lenses
because if you look at the title of this
video cheapest and best lenses for dslr
talk about cheapest like you wanna know
it's cheaper than an 800 lens for your
dslr or mirrorless camera
an old-school manual lens
for 42 dollars on ebay with a little
adapter so that's a pretty hypey title
it's very true and i was and it was a
adapting nikon lenses to canon cameras
with what was called a photo diox
converter and here's here's an example
of that 44 converter so here's here's
the strategy
i'm adding valuable content i'm
answering specific questions i'm
reviewing specific products i'm serving
a particular group of people it's also a
recession people's you know
money is is tight but she still people
still got a market people still are
getting married people still want to do
stuff people are still wedding
videographers so i'm putting content out
there right and i just punch fear in the
face and i start making these videos you
can see again this is just a bedroom
this is in seattle
and we moved to vegas in 2011 because by
the way i didn't go full time at this
point
i eventually accepted a church a role at
a church in las vegas to be their
communications pastor
because my wife was sick
um
she almost died in 2009
and she was dealing with
some health issues we had all these
medical bills piling up
and so i've
sometimes men ask me this question too
they're like i gotta go in all in right
now on youtube and i'm like maybe not
actually you might want to go where you
can get health insurance first because
your family needs to come first
you can also hustle bro and if i get to
speak to you if you're like the main
breadwinner for your family first thing
is you cannot take on too much risk
so
i was like okay i'm gonna do this
youtube thing
but i need something solid and thank god
a door opened up that i was able to go
get a salary
40 000 or something like that with
healthcare
and then oh now i got a full-time job i
can't chase my dreams are you kidding me
i've been chasing my dreams since i made
this video
like i was full-time and faithful at my
job working and being more valuable than
my 40 000 and a year salary and
doing as much as i could to make videos
build upside income invest in my skills
learn everything that i could
so i just want to encourage you
like you can do this but start a side
hustle so this was the size side hustle
i started and to recap the model for you
again number one i started making
youtube videos number two i focus on a
particular kind of videos answer
specific questions and review specific
products number three i started doing
affiliate marketing i got a little bit
of ad revenue but i started to get
people clicking on affiliate links and i
started earning extra money now this
does not only work in tech or cameras or
lenses although it is that is a great
niche for the for it
but that's what i started and you can i
mean the history is online too you know
this the history is not a mystery like
you can go look at the history of think
media the journey's been crazy i mean
today we got heather and omar and and
nolan but you could go back you could
see me hustling i'm talking how to
record skype interviews
back when there was no stream yard i
sound like
just like the
grumpy old
38 year old sean cannell with another
boy on the way and a two-year-old there
was no stream yard
all there was was skype and the
sketchiest like
vod recorders but i mean we were trying
to what is this situation here
you know i'm out there once again the
white sheet is not behind me
and i'm explaining how to record you
know how to do your shot composition but
to use this thing called vod burner
is vodburner still out there yo we still
got an affiliate link for capture skype
crystal clear man i need to go see maybe
they owe me money so i'm talking about
you know how to record skype interviews
i'm i'm making videos i'm doing
interviews i'm hustling this this entire
time and so for the next five years by
the way
i got my main hustle
my main calling and my main purpose and
my main providing for my family
of working at a church
and the whole time i'm grinding on my
side hustle
what's the point number three this is
the time to start a side hustle
and this is i know i'm coming with some
intention energy but this is why when
some people complain like oh my gosh
this came out of nowhere now all of a
sudden our finances are disrupted what
were you doing in peace time
the more you sweat in peace the less you
bleed in war
you got to be hustling when things maybe
aren't bad and then when things get bad
you're like huh
it looks like we built our house on the
rock and not the sand and we can
actually weather this storm
so i'm hustling so i'm doing a side
hustle what's your side hustle are you
working on a side hustle have you
started a side hustle here's the journey
and by the way i didn't know what i know
now i was doing my best reading every
book i could buying every course i could
you know learning on the side going to
events when i could studying what i
could and there wasn't even there wasn't
things like the think media podcast
there was no youtube books out like this
was like the wild west days like things
were just getting started in this era
right and so
ultimately start a side hustle is the
takeaway and uh i got another tip for
you and i want to answer some of your
questions i got actually some more on
this side hustle thing and why it's such
a big idea uh but today's coffee with
cannell show is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
by the way and if you want to
specifically learn my methodology in
depth step by step i just recorded a
live web class this week we have the
replay up this is only it's not for
everybody but it'd only be for you if
you specifically were curious okay what
are the mechanics what are the steps of
actually building a profitable youtube
channel starting or growing one we have
a it's a 67 minute web class with all
those tactics and whatnot i highly
recommend checking that out in fact uh
here's a quick video with details are
you ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
so check it out fakemasterclass.com
limited replay link in the description
down below thanks for being here at
coffee with ken we're talking all about
uh the creator economy and an urgent
warning for all content creators
this is not just fear hype this is
preparedness planning and forecasting of
what's coming ahead and then positive
actions that we can take like number one
cutting unnecessary spending number two
investing and learning valuable skills
number three starting a side hustle and
i want to just speak to something else
on this before we hit number four and
it's this
taxes wow we just lost hat we just lost
everybody there that killed the average
veteration at that moment right now but
listen here's one of the reasons why you
also need to start a side hustle
tax advantages
and i mentioned the book rich dad poor
dad this shifted my thinking back in
2008 and it was why literally everyone
should start a business why for tax
advantages now here was data from 2008.
uh the most recent irs data revealed
that americans who filed taxable returns
paid an average income tax of fifteen
thousand three hundred and twenty two
dollars and i want you to hear that
fifteen thousand three hundred and
twenty two dollars
was paid to the irs by the average
american household in 2018.
one of the most under estimated bills on
your
checking and balance every month for
your personal income is taxes
and unfortunately because of a lack of
financial income a lack of financial
education a lot of creators many in the
crater economy many that are doing
incredibly well
are undereducated about taxes but it
doesn't even matter if you're not doing
well even if you're just working a w-2
job or whatever your job is
what could you do
with 15 322 dollars
not paid to the irs now i'm not
suggesting you don't pay taxes i'm down
to pay my fair share we pay taxes by the
way you can check you want to see our
tax returns you know some people don't
let you see ours um and and so i'm not
i'm not suggesting but what's
interesting
is the tax code here's the unlock
is written giving advantages to business
owners why because business owners
create value in the economy eventually
they employ people because business
owners buy real estate lease office
space they stimulate the economy
so as taught in the book rich dad poor
dad and many other places one of the
reasons why you want to start a business
is for taxes let's go deeper
even if you start according and i'm not
a cpa check out my friend matt bontrager
we'll have him on the think media
podcast soon but one of the reasons why
you want to start
a business on the side even if watch you
don't make money in year one or year two
is because you can start taking
legitimate write-offs
of your income and you can actually lose
money the first couple years look this
up
i'm not a cpa this is not financial
advice but you can look this up
eventually the irs will classify your
business as a hobby
but they understand that when you're
starting up a new business
start a side hustle
that it takes time to get that thing
going and that even if you earn one
thousand five thousand ten thousand
fifteen thousand dollars twenty thousand
dollars
that most likely you're going to
reinvest those dollars into your
business that's why they give you the
write-ups
because
it takes money to keep making more money
and to grow your business
so they're giving you the chance why
should you they want you to have more
money in your hands to grow your
business faster
so what does this look like practically
it means that when you start a business
and you switch your mindset which this
is the mindset that we got to switch in
response this is why this is an urgent
message for creators you got to switch
your mindset
you don't want to just be going into
this thing like this is just a hobby i'm
just dabbling you want to go into this
thing like a business owner realizing
you're the ceo of your business even if
it's just you
and approaching it not with a dabbling
mindset but with the dominating mindset
specifically
when you start a creator economy
business you can start taking legitimate
write-offs like computer monitors
computers cameras boom arms like
education you can write off the books
you buy on amazon you can write off the
journal you buy and the pens you buy and
the wi-fi router and all of these tools
because these are all my business tools
these are all the things that are for my
business now watch a lot of people they
game they do east they
they buy a gaming pc
but if they're not streaming
then they have to buy that with after
tax dollars they pay the irs 15 000
and then whatever money is left over
they spend on their hobbies
here's an idea what if you turned your
hobby into a real business
see my hobby as you can see in the past
was photography
cameras
gear
all that kind of stuff but then i
realized man if i start a business
i'm reading rich dad poor dad okay if i
start a business
this camera is actually a tax deduction
now of course check with your cpa
and you got to use it for business
purposes and sometimes there's
percentages and that's you know i
there's nothing more than a prize than
being ethical and having integrity so
you want to learn about and do your due
diligence diligence on this and i want
to go too deep let me know if this is
valuable here's the big idea start a
side hustle and more practically start a
business
even if and watch
we started our business clear vision
media parent company
are over everything right now it's clear
vision media
we started that in 2009 sonia and i did
and
we also started it literally
in the hardest season of our life and
now fast forward i look back
and i hope this is valuable to you man
in a recession we started a business and
we started getting educated and we
started investing in our skills and we
started hustling and we started putting
out content we started making videos
and and little by little we climbed out
of debt little by little we climbed
we were able to pay off medical bills
little by little we lost houses back in
the last recession we had a rental
property in the house we were living in
we lost them all and our credit was
destroyed
fast forward to today we have multiple
houses you know airbnb property and all
this stuff
it
this isn't like hype overnight success
stuff this is takes the decade of hard
work labor intentionality and strategy
stuff but this is why you want to start
a side hustle
because what can happen now is instead
of earning 20 000 in your side business
25 000 or whatever it is eventually and
then having to pay
uh
24 of that or 30 of that or 10 of that
to the irs you can actually start
writing paying no taxes on that business
income because you keep reinvesting in
your business and you're going to
probably do that anyways
i get on planes i fly to conferences
that's a write-off
i'm going to be going to vid summit
right in la
plane write off hotel write-off just
going is not a write-off
just going as a hobby to an event it's
not a write-off going out to dinner
having a business conversation with uh
partners people you're gonna potentially
collaborate with
50 of that meal you can write off
during the pandemic and lockdown they
change it to 100 to stimulate the
economy is this valuable
so listen start a side hustle okay
because this is the time to do it this
is the time to learn it this is the time
to go all in and i got one more tip for
you
um and uh it's this number four stay on
offense
stay on offense this is what's known as
the strategic offensive principle of war
you ready
the best defense
is a good offense
okay
the idea is is that a strong offensive
action instead of a passive attitude
will pre-occupy
the opposition and ultimately hinder its
ability to mount an opposing
counter-attack leading watch to a next
strategic advantage
see here's what's going to happen
potentially over the next coming months
some people
are going to retreat
some people
are going to freeze
but some people are going to take
massive strategic action
and are going to benefit
why because fortune favors the bold
you got to stay on offense
now this isn't about being careless
listen
build up your emergency fund if anyone
follows dave ramsey or just anybody
that's wise with finances
you should have
good defense
sure
but
you can't win without actually being on
defense we can't just hunker down and
hope that everything is gonna work
itself out
you gotta rise up and find that fight
inside of you to say okay
even though and i i think back to when
we were starting all this kind of stuff
when i uploaded this this video right
here
i the reason i was shooting this video
in front of this bookshelf this is in
the corner
of a mother-in-law
of a house
that we were house hacking
upstairs is matt and amanda and their
daughter in the master bedroom
next to them is kimberly or matt
not at the same time but two different
other roommates and then downstairs and
the mother-in-law
in the corner of the mother-in-law the
pile of all my crap
and computer and like
business
was was me shooting this first video on
think media
and i started creating and i started
making videos
and look at this this august 23 2010
this is the base
the most dismal 2008 nine had gotten the
housing price is about the base of the
housing price
it's the lowest parts of the economy
here in the u.s
and again this is telling my real story
in this moment
my wife had almost died and was in the
hospital for six days
our church
that i was part-time staff on in
marysville washington
was falling apart it had 1600 people
there on easter
some senior leaders stole some money
they took some scriptures out of context
leadership got toxic
and the whole thing imploded
i'm i'm there shell shocked
and then again
on top of that this house
we're trying to short sell it and
eventually we have to leave this house
our credit is destroyed
and
here's my point i'm not trying to lack
empathy saying
you might not be going through it now or
you're not going to go through in the
future i was going freaking through it
but i didn't shrink back into a cocoon
and just go defensive mode
and listen sometimes you gotta rest
you gotta you gotta manage your own
mental health and there might be some
seasons to take a nap take a break back
off i'm not telling anyone to push into
burnout but here's what i am telling you
there's something about
staying on offense
it's that quote that we started out with
that quote that said
the best way to not feel hopeless is to
get up and do something so i had a
choice
i could have just said woe is me and i
would have a lot of reasons i had a lot
of reasons
i could have said
can't believe these leaders around me
can't believe i trusted these people
how could they be double-minded how
could they be so hypocritical
man god why is my wife sick why is she
going through this and i was asking
those questions and i was wrestling with
those questions in prayer
but for in the mystery and the tensions
that we experienced this side of
eternity
i could have gotten stuck in despair
i could have been like
why didn't by the way we had bad advice
people told us like this is a good time
to buy a house it's a good time to
invest our real estate agent pushed us
into uh this other house
and and the inspector overlooked a bunch
of stuff it was like his friend helped
him close the deal we got screwed
there's black mold in the house the roof
was collapsing this is true story the
drain seal field failed that's a 7 000
fix
you want to talk about excuses
you want to talk about getting punched
in the gut you want to talk about being
out of breath wanting to give up and
give in
i could have done that
but i hope that if this helps just one
person
i refused
to only play defense
you have
to play
offense and my friend
one of the best ways to not feel
hopeless is to get up and do something
all right let's start honey let's sit
down let's look over our expenses let's
look at our savings what can we sell why
things are still good let's start
flipping some stuff on ebay this is some
facebook marketplace time let's see if
we could do some couch flipping let's
get this thing going maybe we can down
sell downsize our house right now shoot
let's sell our house right now at the
top of the market let's rent something
smaller let's gather our cash can we
invest in our skills what kind of side
hustle could we start right now i know
things are discouraging i know things
are hard but let's start a side hustle
how can we adapt and pivot in this time
how can we position ourselves to thrive
in the future listen you need a good
defense but you're never going to win
the game if you don't play
offense
don't freeze it's time to take action
hey are you getting value today hit the
mic uh the mic button hit the
you gotta just press record hit
the
like button my name is sean cannell
rhymes with youtube channel and uh let
me know if you have any questions
related to this uh today's episode of
coffee with kannel is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com if specifically i'm
not saying youtube is the only side
hustle there's a lot of them
but if specifically you want to learn
about youtube and you're interested in
uh our uh you know methodology our
methodology is not the only one
but if you are interested in over the
last few years how i built a six-figure
income making youtube videos the
specific strategies i did then and some
of the best strategies for growing three
strategies guaranteed to get views
that's a big guarantee but i actually
guarantee that if you follow what i
teach in the class you will get views on
youtube so
thickmasterclass.com that's out there if
you got a question i'll start to answer
one or two questions coffee with kennel
is the show today i'm coming at you from
the pacific northwest i'm sipping on
some delightful columbia single origin
coffee that i just arrow pressed up let
me know what you're drinking four
question marks before and after your
question i'll be right back with you
in just one second
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at think thinkmasterclass.com
yes yes check it out
thickmasterclass.com link in the
description jt i appreciate you thanks
for the super chat grateful for you uh
sidechat just about to hit a thousand
subs and about to be monetized do you
have a video you recommend
on your channel step by step to insert
ads
i do actually if you want to learn all
about monetization
now you might not be interested in all
of this information but uh
this would be the one it's monetization
explained how to monetize
uh your videos
step by step
and so i'm logged into the wrong account
here without my youtube premium on our
think media account so i am bothered by
these ads but here we go um so this
video youtube monetize explained five
ways to earn money and how youtube pays
you this is step by step for qualifying
for monetization
everything you need to know
and so if you want to learn more about
monetization
steps to getting paid how to verify your
identity so that might be interesting to
you or others that are here let me just
give you a crash course on ads uh in the
actual youtube studio
once you're monetized uh here's what we
like to do um on any individual video uh
what we do
is we go in here to
monetization uh we do overlay ads
skippable ads non-skippable ads we do
not do sponsored cards just because we
figure i mean some of these other things
would take them to take people off the
platform but
that's just a choice we've made i've
interviewed a lot of creators and they
don't either and so you could try them
but we just leave that one unchecked and
then as far as where the ads are we do
before uh the video during the video and
after we just check all the boxes and
here's here's kind of why too
youtube then places the ads
so it doesn't mean an adult play just
because you check the box um and so we
just check all the boxes now what you
can do is you can go into manage
pre-rolls if the video is over eight
minutes and you can add multiple ad
spots
this one only has one at the end
and these are placed automatically so i
i haven't even looked at this i don't
think anyone on the team has we just
changed pick it and then
youtube makes it up so let's look at
something like this is a 27 minute video
okay
uh and this video
let's see where the mid rolls are so
there's one at like
this is random like youtube auto
generates this based on i don't know
what
the final thing what you can do is what
you could do is add manual ad breaks and
on some videos we do that if the video
is kind of like structured for example
if there's like a part one a part two
and a part three you could almost treat
those ad breaks as like a commercial
break in some cases you could overly add
ad breaks and it could increase your
revenue but it might frustrate the
viewers some viewers won't even see it
if they have youtube premium and just
because you put five ad breaks in a
video doesn't mean all five will play
um so
what is the there's no black and white
answer to what's right or wrong i mean
let me know if you're watching this do
you ever get frustrated because of too
many ads has it ever
made you want to unsubscribe to somebody
or if you really wanted the content did
you just endure for it are you a youtube
premium user tell me here in our
community your experience with uh ads
because
uh i know it's it's a debated thing
ultimately i know this
here's my summary
i don't i think we pay for hulu premium
like whatever the highest level is and i
don't know why i still they're still ads
and what i know is that the show's an
hour long
hulu makes me watch like six ads i know
i'm not happy about it
but i know i want to watch snow piercer
till the end so i watch the you know i
like what am i going to do i like and
what i don't complain like i just i'm
like all right i mean this is
this is life and so creator's got to
make money youtube's got to make money
you choose your own amount of amount of
ad spends you want spots you want to add
and i hope that quick tutorial was
helpful new fi appreciate you hit like
if you're getting value is there a way
to get affiliate marketing to work for
entertainment type channels
where i don't promote sell products and
services so
it's it's good you bring this up because
the goal is to pick the right business
model
for your type of content typically if
it's an entertainment channel your best
business model is to do like an
integration with a brand that actually
is woven into the content so it's
usually ad revenue brand deals maybe
something like patreon or crown funding
so sometimes you don't want to try to
force a strategy that doesn't really
work well but now consider this you
potentially could still integrate
let's say audible you know an audible's
an audiobook app right and i think about
sean chandler who's one of our video
ranking academy students and so what he
did was he does literally entertainment
content he like reviews or rather talks
about
ranks the three it movies stephen king's
it the original one and the two new ones
and what he did as he was like ranking
those and reviewing those was he was
like hey by the way did you know you can
like listen to stephen king's it on
audiobook for free actually if you don't
have an audible account
and i'll put a link in the description
so he gives like a call to action to it
it's not like a like a product it's like
a related here watch he's integrating
audible but it wasn't a brand deal
and then here's the numbers what ends up
happening
is he
anyone who clicks his link and signs up
to download stephen king's it for free
if it's a new audible account he gets
five to ten dollars just for them
signing up
so did you see like you can kind of do a
brand deal without even doing a brand
deal you could do an integration say
click the link in the bio in the link
in the description and the link could be
an affiliate link
so that would be my advice is you got to
be more
think about integrating
in a non-forceful
relevant value-adding way
product services things that are
relevant
and the last thing i would say
new fi is you got to ask
what is the intent of the viewer this is
why i highly recommend if you're
watching this
one of the video types that you make
should be what we call rsp review
specific products why
because when someone goes to youtube
looking for a product review let's look
at one of our students here's jennifer
from the sewing report okay
so
now maybe it's a little more obvious but
this is think about it so this is
a sewing channel diy crafts
okay
now there's also
videos that are not product related
watch this before starting an etsy shop
here's how to do a particular tutorial
but a lot of what she does
is also related like reviewing these
these brother
sewing machines so now this video
has 455 000 views
and in the description she has an
affiliate link to amazon for
the uh
you know product of course
and so
this is jen from the sewing report
okay
and so if we look in the description you
could see that if we go down here and
click a link on this
sewing machine
she's going to get like four percent of
this probably
and and so now of course she's making
money and she was able to quit her job
uh her family's able to buy a house it's
pretty crazy their story
but ultimately
here's the point you don't have to be a
product review channel to do product
reviews
make sense
so
this is why
we spend so much time at think media
not just trying to help you figure out
your niche but trying to help you figure
out your business plan your positioning
your business model
because those decisions
are like the beginning decisions that
are the lead domino that affect
everything else that's down the line
and if you're positioned right and
you're making not only product reviews
but then watch
imagine if she talks about these right
and
then she also does like baby gifts if
someone subscribes because they find her
and they like her product review video
only if she did it like once a month
or once a quarter
it also brings in the right audience if
you're talking about the right things
because other people that are into
crafts sewing they connect with you so
it's not this idea like people always
make the mistake i don't want to just do
like a product review channel it's the
only way to make money with affiliate
marketing
no i mean
it's just a piece of the overall
strategy but when you make videos that
are rsp review specific products you can
make money easiest way to start making
money you don't have to be monetized to
start doing affiliate marketing
two
they bring in the right subscribers if
you do it right
three
you don't even have to keep doing it but
it's a good way to get going
and cash flow
solves your problems early on so you
could go full time faster go part-time
at your job so anyways uh
i got a super chat here to talk about if
you want more on that that's that is
what i just talked about at the
masterclass thinkmasterclass.com
one of the strategies on there is rsp
review specific products i have other
case studies too
you'd be surprised by how many different
niches uh this works in and so
definitely check
all of that out let me see if i can find
this super chat hit like if you get
value today what are you doing this
weekend let me know and uh i want to
honor this super chat
thank you so much
architectural sheet metal for 10
canadian
niche qualified i want to put all my
efforts into it because i see a lot of
potential and i'm a pioneer in my
industry
but i'm tech would you recommend i go
full time as soon as possible
well i mean yeah why not go full time as
soon as possible but here's the big
question should you go full time
uh here's what i'd like to measure one
do you need money
legitimate question a friend of mine
nikki philippi when she first started
her youtube career she got a vision for
it
um she's one of the first interviews on
video influencers
and
her husband was working full-time so
they sat down and they talked and they
made a plan that's a tip make a plan
with your family if you have a family or
dependents or a partner
and she said i really think i want to go
all in on this he goes cool
you can no kids so season of life second
tip season of life what season are you
in
so he's like okay you go all in i'm
going to keep working so she starts to
go to coffee shops where she like she
would shoot at like home she'd like to
edit at coffee shops she started to work
8 9 10 11 12 hour days grinding about
six months full time on youtube
now some of us don't have
that luxury you might say man that
sounds awesome i got a day job well
that's your circumstances you gotta you
can't wish
you know you were in the situation that
somebody else has
the grass really isn't greener on the
other side
the grass is greener where you water it
you got to work your land proverbs says
work your land he who works his land
will have abundance of food
but those who chase his fantasies is
gonna suffer lack you gotta work your
land
you gotta work your circumstance you
gotta work your situation work your land
like what's your circumstance
so can you go full time do you have
reserves um but i want to give you the
final metric for
should you go full time
bring it in
bring it in for this one
let's
get a little more light
all right
so
this is what's called the
20 rule
and if you're trying to determine should
i go all in as a creator in my online
business
in my side hustle maybe youtube is just
a vehicle of something else you're doing
your course creator you're an artist
this is the 25 rule the 25 rule is this
you start doing your side hustle
and you start generating some income on
the side
uh
two you sit down and you really figure
out how much you need to live on a month
and i don't mean how much you need to
live on a month
freaking door dashing every night you
need to knock that off
get back to the grocery store and start
cooking some food and start saving
hundreds of dollars a month ubereats is
not your friend
it's your credit card's enemy
okay
you do whatever you want but but you get
the energy
sit down and look at your
your monthly expenses and figure out a
solid number honey
what do we need to live on a month
five grand cool
three thirty five hundred great get
clear on that number step three
you've been working your side hustle a
little bit of money is coming in
two dollars and 12 cents in affiliate
marketing
wow
but that's pretty cool
then adsense you finally get approved
then you start to merge self
made an online course like whatever got
100 bucks 200 bucks coming in
and you're hustling on your side hustle
when you
are earning roughly 25
of your needed monthly income
so let's say it's four grand a month is
what you need and you figured that out
because you just sat down and did some
simple math and looked at your budget
rent food
nails
eyelashes you know whatever
are the essentials for that month
and for your life
you get to a thousand dollars in your
side hustle
that's probably the time to jump
that's probably the time to go all in
now mind you you're still 3 000 short of
how much you need to pay your your bills
every month
and so it's still scary
but here's what the 25 percent rule does
for you
it's proof of concept and it's proof
that while you had your full-time main
job or whatever you were able to build
up your income on the side so that when
you put your two weeks notice in and you
go all in you'll be able to scale
the 25 of your monthly income that you
need up really quickly
is it a guarantee nothing's a guarantee
you might get hit by a meteorite five
minutes from now like nothing's
guaranteed but ultimately
i really like the 25 rule because it's a
good
methodology i mentioned i was working at
a church i'm making youtube videos i'm
talking about tech i'm doing affiliate
marketing and i grew my income up to
about
300 to 500 a month in amazon affiliate
revenue and about a hundred dollars in
adsense it's only 600 bucks and we
needed about 4 000 a month for our
family to live and when i lost all my
freelance clients which was in 2015 in
october
uh
i it was i already had proof of concept
i wasn't starting from zero and being
like now i'm going full time so i'm a
big advocate that you you
unless you
have some money you have some startup
capital i mean you really got to
evaluate your circumstances i'm a big
advocate for
go wait tables like go do something and
then even if it's part time and then
build this thing up so that you you know
you do it at the right
time when there's proof of concept when
you've hit that 25 number
and from there you can scale it up hope
that's helpful
um
all right my friends
i agree luke a meteorite is a horrible
way to go it might not be that bad of a
way to go though because i mean you
think about it
like you wouldn't really know probably
like all of a sudden it'd just be over
so i mean that's that might be better
uh okay hit like if you're getting value
and uh i want to thank you for being a
part of coffee with cannell today
nona how do you make merch to sell
without influence i don't think you
should i think you should build
influence first in our video influencers
today we used to say helping you build
your influence your income and your
impact that wasn't just a catchy tag
line that was an actual framework you
got to build your influence first
because influence leads to income you're
not going to make income if no one's
watching your videos and you're not
going to ultimately make an impact if no
one's watching your videos and you can't
make a difference live today like no one
else so that's eventually you can live
and give like no one else that's a dave
ramsey quote i believe that business
like for example i think media we're
deeply passionate not just about serving
the creator economy and taking care of
our team but like we partner with
compassion international for example we
sponsor 101 kids
every month to get food to get education
to get discipled to be planted in a
local church in a really hard situations
relief from different disasters all
kinds of different things you can check
out compassion i think dot org is the
website
so listen that's a lot that's a lot of k
i mean when we want to do more like how
many do you want to do sean all of them
like we want to we want to keep growing
we keep adding to them every year what's
the point
i think that that heart and that
desire to make a difference you can't
give much when you can't even pay your
own bills build your influence first get
your income going and then you can make
a greater impact and we want to keep
multiplying our impact but we got to
keep building our influence so we can
generate more income so we can reinvest
those dollars so we can build our
business more and out of abundance or
overflow ultimately give
so i don't think you make a merch shelf
before you have influence i think you
focus solely on building influence
first
my friends hit the like button thank you
for being here today if you want to go
check out my class
thickmasterclass.com uh we have a
limited replay up for a couple days uh
there and there's like a special offer
we're doing on video ranking academy
which is our online course full
transparency whether that's right for
you or not no worries check out the
class regardless 67 minutes of valuable
tactical information that i think you're
gonna love hit the like button if you
got value today and i want you to click
or tap the screen if
you actually need more time in a week to
get all your content done heather did a
two-part series all about uh how to be
more productive 15 productivity tips so
you actually can get your videos done
even if this is a side hustle for you i
appreciate you my name is sean cannell
rhymes with youtube channel and i will
see you on the next episode of coffee
with kennel